bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à strasbourg pour ce nouveau numéro d'
europe et juri aujourd'hui focus sur la
grèce françois hollande est est en
visite officielle
c'est la deuxième fois qu'il se rend
dans le pays mais cette fois il était
accompagné de grands patrons qui veulent
investir dans le pays
la grèce serait sur la voie de la
guérison regarder
en grèce françois hollande n'est pas
venu seul
il est accompagné de son ministre de
l'économie michel sapin
ici en train de signer des accords avec
son homologue grec accompagne le chef de
l'état aussi cinq grands patrons
français
on est venu faire du business le pays
est à vendre et il ya des affaires à
saisir déjà vendu une partie du pirée le
port d'athènes au chinois vendus aussi
quatorze aéroports régionaux aux
allemands pour plus d'un milliard
d'euros solde et des plages et des
marinas à des investisseurs turcs et
arabes
450 millions d'euros mais pour
rembourser ses créances la grèce doit
vendre plus et c'est là que les français
voudraient entrer dans la danse
mais ici pas question d'en parler à
haute voix discrétion oblige devant le
parlement grec
un françois hollande réaffirme son
soutien aux grecs en se disant
favorables à une renégociation de leur
dette
il y avait des réformes a fait les grecs
les ont adoptés gala d'autres encore à
mener
et c'est dans ce cadre là qui peut y
avoir qu il y aura un allègement la
charge de la dette et pour alléger la
charge de la dette
il faut continuer les privatisations et
les entrepreneurs français veulent leur
part du gâteau grecques restent à vendre
les routes et les autoroutes un gros
marché qui intéresserait le groupe de
btp vinci
les chemins de fer aussi sont à céder
pour la maintenance le géant alstom se
tient prêt les français sont à la traîne
à la 4e place des investissements en
grèce mais ils sont optimistes c'est le
bon moment pour investir des
investisseurs en position de force la
grèce est sous pression
le pays s'est engagé à retirer 50
milliards d'euros de ces privatisations
alors nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
deux eurodéputés d'abord ces lieux
school oglou bonjour bonjour vous êtes
euro députés grecs élu sous les couleurs
de syriza le parti d'alexis presse vous
êtes aussi un homme de télévision très
connu me dit on engraisse à vos côtés
inge grèce le bonjour je vous êtes
eurodéputée allemande de la cd où le
parti d'angela merkel alors venu de voir
ce reportage beaucoup de prix de
privatisations à la grèce qui vendent un
peu ses bijoux de famille est ce que la
grèce est à vendre et à n'importe quel
prix stelios loglo sais pas ce qui est
malheureusement on est obligés à vendre
beaucoup de choses à bon marché et vous
savez qu'à une condition pourquoi ne
connaissions pas et kate pour qu'elle
aille man sin les mémorandums s'est
montrée dira d'ailleurs d'été était
qu'il est le gouvernement vend les 14
lots pauvres parce que le gouvernement
précédent décidées jaboulay rien négocié
les quatorze aéroports le contrat mais
sur quoi passe du temps parce que le
gouvernement les avait vendues à trop
batterie les amendements du gouvernement
précédent le président oui on voulait
aller négocier mais pas ni à la hausse
des prix oui mais demandé une meilleure
repris pas pas nier le la nécessité de
vendre les aéroports ou des privatisé
que vous voulez mais quand même il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'il fallait faire
autrement et si il y avait des
partenaires qui se comporterait comme
partenaire et pas comme créanciers
bilatéraux visé l'allemagne là ne sont
pas des partenaires ce sont des
créanciers vous êtes interpellé inglès
le tout à fait des créanciers mais on
est des créanciers parce qu'on croit que
la grèce peut y arriver et c'est pour ça
qu'on a dit privatisation pas
privatisation pour cause pour qu'on
privatise les choses mais pour que
l'économie puisse se relancer pour créer
aussi les emplois parce que ce qu'on
voit ce que les aéroports grecs sont
sous valeur maintenant sous valorisé par
l'état grec
des investissements manque dont il faut
prendre beaucoup d'argent à la main faut
vraiment faire profiter pleinement de
ses possibilités qu'offre
c'est un report c'est pour ça que je ne
crois pas qu'on les a eu de bons marchés
non le travail est encore devant et je
vous assure
les aéroports grecs font encore parfois
près partie du réseau de fraport tu
l'aéroport de francfort c'est une
société privée et je crois que ça va
l'état grec et le peuple grec va en
profiter alors je suis désolé de voir
que la privatisation est vu comme on
vend les bijoux de famille non on essaye
de vraiment faire de donner à la grèce
est assise à un report toutes les
chances et la même chose va arriver avec
les progrès que vous allez voir
bon mais écouter mais quand même pas
dans les négociations d'été qui m'aime
me suive les menaces et qui est pour les
grecs site
il a demandé que le ministre allemand
des finances et tous les biens grec
alimentaires des séquanes milliards
d'euros soit transférée à une obscure
institutes à luxembourg contrerait
indirectement par lui même mais ce qui
est terrible et ça on ne l'a pas accepté
mais c'est parce que c'est pas tout
l'allemagne qui passe comme ça
évidemment évidemment pas mais il ya des
équipages comme ça et c'est ce qui me
passait plutôt d'un assassin économique
quête d'un partenaire
c'est ça que je voulais dire laissez-moi
rappelé que l'allemagne les créanciers
de presque 100 milliards d'euros alors
on aime sur le non non non contribuables
dans cet argent-là 100 milliards d'euros
oui on est oui on aimerait bien avoir la
garantie que cet argent n'est pas perdu
c'est pour ça que je ne peux que
vraiment faire pression sur le
gouvernement grec de mettre en oeuvre
tout le programme pour vraiment créer la
relance de la situation grecque de l'âme
de l'économie en grèce la situation est
dangereuse pour nous deux et pour la
grèce et pour l'allemagne et pour la
france
en grèce les change les choses bougent
quand même en grèce j'ai listé à le
blocage des capitaux inciter les grecs à
se convertir à la carte bleue 1 et à
limiter l'argent liquide les
déclarations fiscales sont désormais
informés informatisé à bercy a aidé à
construire un meilleur système fiscal
les élections de septembre ont permis à
alexis tsipras de prendre de la distance
vis-à-vis de son aile gauche
plus dure est d'adopter quelques
réformes à une loi vient d'être votée
augmenter les taxes une tva à 23% les
choses bougent en grèce est ce que lui
pays étant est en voie de guérison
écoutez on s'est passé en direct pendant
les bombardiers passer des élections on
a arrêté deux oligarques grecque
il chante mettre en prison on arrêtait
plis des oligarques qui elle est les
alliés demandent ma dang est rugueuse se
sont arrêtés pendant quatre décennies
alors on a arrêté des gens qui est qui a
été condamné à la perpétuité terre à
cause de placements d'argent ils étaient
marchands des armes et menteur qui ce qu
il était le match à des éléments ils
vendent et agressé des chars allemands
d'ailleurs on l'avouera j'étais à la
prison on essaye d appliquer les
réformes et de respecter notre signature
le problème c'est qu'ils les programmes
et à ses dires à cinq prochaines
l'austérité par la motorisation on nous
voulons appliquer des réformes beaucoup
puisque les partenaires européens mais
il y à l'austérité qui est très dire je
vous donne un câble tv tv à 23%
elle est tous les airbus mettra doivent
payer 100 % de l'impôt pour l'année
prochaine ils sont surtaxés mais aussi
ils vont payer ça ne passe pas elle part
dans le monde ça se passe en grèce ça
c'est très difficile pour les crises
grecque et ça il faut il faut faire
beaucoup de défauts le strip tease cette
victimisation de la grèce je veux
rappeler quand même que ce gouvernement
a tout fait sur la victimisation ce qui
vient dire oui c'est ça c'est la grèce
est victime d'elle-même un peu parce que
le gouvernement a tout fait pour
aggraver la situation économique et
financière
et c'est le grec si tu sais pas les
créanciers qui ont poussé la grèce à la
grecque c'est aux grecs si tu sais
humaine c'est vous même qui vous ont
poussée par des mesures n'ont pris au
crack site c'était une situation quand
même dramatique du jamais vu et les
contrôles des capitaux continuent
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et je dois vous dire
qu'en ce moment c'est la troîka
en grèce les institutions dont le
résultat c'est que de 40,2 points à
mettre en oeuvre
il y a que 14 qui ont été mis en oeuvre
c'est pour ça que 2 milliards d'euros
somme bloquée alors je ne peux
qu'appeler à la grèce fait ce qu'on a
accordé ensemble on a accordé avec ce
gouvernement aussi tout le monde a signé
et je dois vous dire je n'ai pas de
d'allier oligarches pas que je sache je
dois vous dire que je suis très
préoccupé il faut arrêter ceux qui
violent les lois mais il faut aussi
arriver à un jugement
alors on peut toujours arrêter tout le
monde mais qu'est ce qu'un avec avec le
jugement
c'est ce qui compte pour moi parce que
c'est ça le résultat je vais vous
observez ça comme vous me l'avez dit je
ne savais pas je dois vous dire que je
suis très préoccupé parce que ça ne
suffit pas de montrer du doigt les
autres fait la fête et c'est ce que
c'est le message que le premier ministre
type racial reçu ici dans cette dans
cette chambre des députés des chefs de
groupe fait le comme ça on ne peut pas
vous aider si vous vous aidez pas vous
même mais pas chez vous madame qu' il
est temps d'arrêter de donner des leçons
ça veut dire les deux plus grands
scandales industrielle des dernières
décennies sont d'origine allemagne les
scada de siemens et maintenant on a les
scandales financiers
vous êtes vous avez même donner des pots
de vin pour gagner l'organisation du
mondial de 2006 alors madame la reine
est mis il faut pas il faut arrêter de
donner des leçons aux autres il faut se
comporter comme un partenaire et pas
comme eux sont mécontents mais mes
professeurs qui donne toujours des
leçons et qui punit les élèves qui
n'obéissent pas aux autres merci pour la
critique fondamentale qui me sert à rien
je dois vous dire que l'allemagne à
aider à la grèce comme parce qu'on n'a
jamais aidé à un pays
jamais on a on vous a aidé on vous
traite de partenaires mais il faut pas
maintenant continuer à ne rien faire
vous savez j'ai un peu marre le scandale
siemens a date de 2004 et je vous assure
siemens et je ne suis pas le responsable
de siemens l'état l'anru c'est un
gouvernement non plus ils ont fait ils
ont ils ont vraiment tout fait pour que
ça n'arrive que on a on a su qu'on
scandale volksbank et ne vous allez voir
quand
vraiment ils vont purifier la maison là
je suis absolument sûr et les américains
ou les forcer à y faire heureusement
c'est pour ça que ceux qui suivent pas
la loi
il faut vraiment tout faire mais ça sert
à rien de ne pas faire ce qu'on a
accordé ensemble c'est pour ça que je ne
peux que vous demander de faire ce qu'il
faut faire
voilà monsieur au même moment il y à la
crise des migrants et pour la contenir
cette crise des migrants bruxelles
annonce la création de cent mille places
d'accueil 30000 places seront créées
pour pour la grèce c'est que la
situation devient critique la semaine
dernière c'est un bébé de moins de 18
mois qui a été sauvé in extremis au
large de la mer egée a regardé les
images sont commentés par quatre gilder
quelque part entre la grèce et la
turquie
ce jour là la mairie calme quand tout à
coup
ces pêcheurs turc aperçoivent au loin
des naufragés trois jeunes enfants qui
appellent au secours très prudemment il
les hisse à bord de leur bateau le temps
de faire un dernier tour pour récupérer
les gilets de sauvetage
et puis soudain c'est un homme est mort
il est vivant
le petit garçon de 18 mois flottait
depuis 5h quasi inconscient mon dieu il
est vivant il faut sortir l'eau de ses
poumons
le pêcheur est un peu surpris des gestes
dans tous les sens qui a lu les pieds
mais lui la tête en bas mon dieu les
tellement petits avaient appelle les
garde-côtes
après quelques heures à l'hôpital
il retrouvera sains et saufs sa famille
cyrielle rescapés elle aussi le nombre
de migrants noyés en mer egée ne cesse
d'augmenter avec l'arrivée de l'hiver
la traversée est de plus en plus
dangereuse voilà des images poignantes
quand vous voyez ces images ce bébé
sauvé in extremis au large de la mer
egée vous vous dites quoi
moi je peux vous dire que la position
adoptée par madame merkel au début de la
crise au sein des très positive digne
d'une chancelière allemande
parce qu'il a été beaucoup critiqué mais
elle garde le cap mais quand même il
faut admettre maintenant et madame grès
les douanes m parce que la grèce disait
déjà il ya cinq ans quatre ans qu'il
faut s'adresser aux problèmes de déficit
ont cassé les problèmes de déchets de
des tapis et maintenant les problèmes
notés quoi alors maintenant tout le
monde comprenne qui lâche ou et la
tragédie et la pression qu'il agrée
chahi pas dans ces zones
quand on demande et décharger des
d'oublier tout ça peuvent sonner ne
voulait pas nous atteindre
la grâce est
c'est la frontière extérieure de l'union
européenne là il ya les obligations
j'aimerais vraiment connaître la grèce
pour remplir ses obligations et là une
emprise plusieurs parts pour que la
grèce puisse remplir ses obligations le
problème c'est que de dire au revoir à
tous ces réfugiés pour les amener en
allemagne c'est ce qui se fait
maintenant ça a des conséquences sévères
chez nous aussi pour l'apprenti
européenne et j'espère que c'est pas ce
que vaut les acteurs partenaires de
coalition du gouvernement a annoncé le
faire j'espère que c'est pas ça te dire
au revoir aux réfugiés pour les amener
en allemagne vous savez pour ce pur
quant à l'intégration à l'acceptation
allons durée de ces réfugiés
l'allemagne fait valoir vingt fois plus
l'année dernière que la grèce est cette
année en fait on fait vraiment ça qu'un
triplé nous on a on a maintenant quatre
cent mille réfugiés demandeurs d'asile
et qui vont rester chez nous et vous
avez 9000 ça c'est une c'est une
relation où il faut en parler il faut
une solution européenne ça c'est clair
c'est pas que la faute de la grèce il ya
beaucoup d'autres pays qui refusent de
prendre des réfugiés réfugiés ce qu'il
faut régler
sinon ceux qui prennent pas les réfugiés
il faut qu'ils payent il faut qu'il paye
ceux qui prennent les réfugiés la grèce
fait beaucoup pour accueillir pour
accueillir les réfugiés nous on voit
tous les jours les scènes à l'espace et
je suis autant désolé que pour les
scènes que je vois à la frontière
bavaroise il n'y a pas de solution
facile c'est pour ça que vous n'allez
pas voir que je me crée elle avec vous
là dessus la grèce demande une rallonge
de 300 millions d'euros 1 pour
accueillir ces migrants le broie pas dû
refuser ce à quoi je crois quand il faut
maintenant pas il faut une solution
européenne il faut que que tout le monde
réfléchisse ensemble ce qu'il faut faire
faut vraiment gérer cette masse de
personnes et c'est pour ça que je ne
peux pas dire oui ou non
mais je crois qu'il faut trouver des
solutions pour ceux qui vraiment
accueille ses réfugiés
il faut aider les pays bas quand il ya
crise lorsque lou merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation nous on poursuit avec
tout autre chose
le statut des fonctionnaires n'est plus
adéquat pour certaines missions
c'est ce qu'a dit emmanuel macron lors
d'un débat il a provoqué à jeudi
pataquès à ce faisant recadré par la
suite par sa hiérarchie
nous sommes allés voir en suède comment
ça se passe là bas il ya des
fonctionnaires mais ils n'ont plus de
statut particulier à ce sont des
salariés comme les autres ils peuvent
même se faire licencier
regardez le reportage à stockholm d'elsa
monde à gaza
depuis le mois d'août 1 à karlsson et
professeur dans un collège public de
stockholm elle y enseigne le français
mais aussi l'anglais en suède ces deux
matières par professeur et ce n'est pas
la seule différence avec le système
français ici les enseignants n'ont pas
d'affectation
ils choisissent eux-mêmes leurs
établissements c'est à moi d'essayer de
poser une candidature dans n'importe
quelle école dans n'importe quelle ville
donc je suis libre c'est presque comme
le marché privé
le marché des écoles oui c'est clair que
c'est très différent que le système
français car ana n'a pas de statut
particulier de fonctionnaires elle est
signé un contrat de droit privé
directement avec la principale de
l'établissement goût ni la haute saône
elle est presque une chef d'entreprise
elle gère le budget alloué par la
municipalité recrute les professeurs et
pour les motiver ou les sanctionner elle
a un moyen de pression
les proviseurs déterminer eux-mêmes les
salaires des professeurs
si je trouve un enseignant pas assez bon
je n'augmente pas je sais qu'en france
c'est très différent et d'ailleurs j'ai
une question pour vous comment vous
faites avec des professeurs avec qui
cela ne marche pas si des professeurs ne
sont pas à la hauteur moi j'ai
l'impression d'avoir les instruments
pour corriger les choses
depuis les années 70 la suède a
profondément réformé son secteur public
les effectifs ont drastiquement diminué
et le statut des fonctionnaires a
disparu l'emploi à vie ne perdure que
pour une infime partie des agents
publics
goun harling rennes était conseiller aux
affaires européennes pour le
gouvernement mais au fil du temps son
activité a diminué jusqu'à disparaître
en 2011 après 34 ans de carrière dans la
fonction publique il est remercié
je n'avais pas peur j'étais ennuyé c'est
sûr mais j'étais aussi curieux de savoir
ce qui allait se passer
j'étais sûr que j'allais retrouver un
emploi ce n'était qu'une question de
temps
je suis resté très optimiste
le procédé
et pour cela il a pu compter sur une
agence spécialisée en suède chargé
d'aider les fonctionnaires licenciés à
retrouver un emploi
les stones et ce souhait des chats job
c'est que ici vous êtes à la tri gate
steve tolleson l' agence pour la
sécurité de l'emploi pour le secteur
public
nous avons été créée en 1990 et depuis
nous avons aidé cent mille personnes
l'agencé affiche de bons résultats avec
dont 80% des cas un retour à l'emploi
dans l'année ce sont les employeurs
publics qui financent cet accompagnement
à hauteur de 0,3 pour cent de leur masse
salariale
un exemple de flexisécurité à la
suédoise
le gouvernement voulait créer plus de
compétitivité dans le secteur public le
rendre plus efficace et pour cela donner
la possibilité de licencier plus
facilement les agents alors il ya eu une
négociation pour créer en contrepartie
un bon filet de sécurité pour les
fonctionnaires qui perdaient leur emploi
et leur accorder de bonne allocation
chômage après avoir essayé de créer sa
propre entreprise
benard a retrouvé du travail dans une
agence publique spécialisée dans les
transports
et quand on lui demande ce qu'il pense
du système suédois
il se montre plutôt philosophe vous
savez tout peut arriver même dans le
secteur public
il ya des réorganisations on demande aux
gens de déménager ailleurs en suède où
parfois comme c'est mon cas
eh bien il n'ya plus assez travail mais
tous ceux qui étaient passés par la mort
assurée et puis de toute façon je
n'avais pas le choix fait par nos
options
on suède cela fait donc plus de 40 ans
que le public se rapproche du privé avec
l'accord des syndicats comme tc au un
des plus importants suè mais si cela ne
fait plus débat
il reste des interrogations sur
l'apparition de contrats précaires dans
le secteur public
il ya aussi une discussion sur la ce
contrat d'une durée déterminée et le
synter hummer et que l'on ne peut avoir
de problème avec la qualité d'un service
public
s'il n'y a pas de continuer t2 les
salariés et ça c'est une discussion sait
qu'ils existent aussi dans le secteur
privé
le système suédois en modèle de
flexisécurité qui fait parfois rêver
d'autres pays d'europe mais qui est loin
d'être transposable partout
voilà un reportage à stockholm signé les
amendes à à gaza nous a rejoints sur ce
plateau robert rochefort
bonjour j'ai trop député élu sous les
couleurs du modem vous êtes économiste
aussi alors on vient de voir le
reportage de les amendes à gavât est ce
que le modèle suédois est transposable
en france non non il ne l'est pas
peut-être qui plaît au cde au suédois
c'est très bien 90% des fonctionnaires
ont disparu en suède il faut que la
france se réforme
c'est incontestable mais je ne crois pas
qu'il faille se réformer en ouvrant
maintenant quelque chose qui est une
opposition absolue qui serait une façon
de braquer les fonctionnaires contre le
non fonctionnaires sur ce statut des
fonctionnaires vous êtes plus macro
mélenchon ou à écouter je dirais que je
suis ni l'un ni l'autre
en revanche je pense qu'il faut des
modernisations il faut que les choses se
rapproche
je vous donne juste un exemple la
semaine dernière les partenaires sociaux
c'est-à-dire trois syndicats plus le
patronat sont tombés d'accord pour en
fait allonger d'un an la durée de vie
professionnelle les salariés du privé
c'est l'accord agirc arrco il n'est pas
normal que les fonctionnaires n'est pas
le même traitement c'est là qu'il soit à
côté de cette réforme il faut petit à
petit faire en sorte que les choses se
rapproche
il faut s'inspirer les uns des autres il
faut moderniser la fonction publique il
faut peut-être que dans certains cas il
n'ya plus des fonctionnaires peut-être
que par exemple pour entretenir les
routes ou pour vérifier l'entrée dans
les musées on n'a pas besoin en tant que
tel de gens qui soient des
fonctionnaires mais le système suédois
serait en france quelque chose qui
provoquera une fracture qui opposerait
les uns aux autres donc en tant que
telle n'est pas un peu hypocrite en
france et à des fonctionnaires mais a
aussi beaucoup de vacataires beaucoup de
deux cdd un non protégés par par le
statut de la fonction publique
oui oui pourquoi parce que nous avons
plusieurs problèmes en france
d'abord nous continuons à recruter des
fonctionnaires ce qui est aberrant et
c'est le cas y compris pour l'année
prochaine dans le lot finances 2016 et
puis il ya un très très gros problème en
france c'est qu'en fait nous ne savons
pas manager des fonctionnaires y un vrai
problème de management
finalement nous avons
probablement trop de fonctionnaires et
nous avons plein d'endroits où le
service est de mauvaise qualité
parce qu'il manque quelque chose qui est
le management alors est ce que le
management
ça consiste dans le qualitatif que le
produit plaît c'est ce que disait la
chef d'établissement dans le reportage
on a vu elle a dit qu'est ce qui se
passe si l'enseignant avec lequel je
suis ne convient pas moi c'est fait moi
j'en ai les moyens le licencie et là il
ya un message pour nous il faut qu'il y
ait beaucoup plus de liberté dans les
chefs d'unité dans la fonction publique
par exemple il faut que les chefs
d'établissement est beaucoup plus
d'autonomie des capacités de négocier et
même d'intervenir en partie sur leur
rémunération de leurs collaborateurs
mais ça c'est possible tout en
détricotant pas l'ensemble de la
fonction publique je vous cite plein
d'autres exemples
il faut par exemple qu'il y ait de la
mobilité à l'intérieur de la force
publique il n'est pas normal qu'au
ministère l'économie vous fassiez
l'école des douanes où vous fassiez
l'école de la statistique ou fassiez
l'école des impôts et qu'en fait vous
soyez enfermé toute votre vie dans un
corps je crois qu'il ya plus de 350
corps de fonctionnaires en france où
vous ne pouvez pas avoir de la mobilité
vous ne pouvez pas changer de métier il
faut amener de la souplesse dans tout
cela
prenons un exemple récent que tout que
tous les français ont connu
prenez l'exemple de france télécom qui
dans le temps était une administration
des télécommunications qui est
maintenant qu est une entreprise
totalement concurrentiel la poste vie
une évolution qui est un petit peu de
même nature
ces évolutions sont bonnes et il faut
même temps être à 110 évolutions sont
naturels on va on va même les au
libéralisme - non non je pense qu'il
faut dire qu'on va vers la modernisation
va vers une europe plus libérale cunhui
sociale alors l'europe c'est être
capable au sein de l'europe de faire
cohabiter des modèles comme la suède et
des modèles comme la france voyez bien
que dans un pays qui est un pays avec
une très grande diversité territoriale
donc nous on serait à l'extrême gauche
alors dans on est on est dans une
situation où on a une tradition qui est
une tradition d'état maintenant il faut
par exemple déconcentrer il faut
décentraliser la réforme des régions qui
étaient mal foutu si elle doit quand
même aboutir à ce qu' il n'y est plus
mais malheureusement je suis pas très
optimiste sur ce point des
fonctionnaires
deux mairies des fonctionnaires de
départements de région et d'état qui
traite les mêmes sujets à la fois ce
serait comment dire une bonne évolution
donc il faut se moderniser il faut
changer il faut de la souplesse mais il
faut beaucoup manuel maquilleront quand
il dit que le statut des fonctionnaires
n'est plus adéquat dans les missions
actuelles
quand il dit ça s'il n'y a pas de dori
l'afnor il n'a pas forcément tort pour
tous s'il le dit comme étant une vérité
révélée pour tous et s'il promeut d'une
certaine façon le système à la suédoise
vous voyez bien qu'il s'agit là d'une
sorte de tactique politicienne pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait au sein de la
gauche des gens extrêmement libéraux et
puis de l'autre côté des gens qui vont
dire mais non il faut absolument pas y
toucher
donc ça c'est ça c'est pas très
intéressant mais mais qu'on soit porteur
d'innovation oui qu'on soit porteur que
par exemple il y ait des contrats privés
à l'intérieur de l'état et qu'il y ait
des gens qui ont fait carrière dans
l'entreprise privée qui viennent pendant
quelques années apporté leur
contribution call inverse il ya la
possibilité pour les fonctionnaires
d'aller travailler en entreprise privée
quand ils le souhaitent c'est évident
qu'il faut amener cette respiration et
qu'il faut amener cette souplesse et je
vous donne juste un dernier exemple
regarder les emplois d'avenir
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre le
chômage on envoie des jeunes dans en
fait l'administration la quasi
administration tout en leur disant même
temps vous serez pas fonctionnaires
parce qu'on va pas embaucher mais en
même temps leur laisse croire que quand
on peut pas trouver d'emploi dans le
privé c'est dans l'administration qu'on
va les accueillir
ça c'est un mauvais plan parce que ça
veut dire que l'administration devient
un choix par défaut mais non pas un
choix par vocation comme ça peut être le
cas par exemple pour les infirmières
pour les gens qui travaillent à
l'hôpital et en même temps on fait des
jeunes qui ne sont pas suffisamment
formés et qui au bout de leur mission d'
emplois d'avenir n'ont qu'une seule
envie c'est de devenir fonctionnaire
pour se protéger du chômage ce que je
comprends très bien
alors que la réponse par exemple ce
serait de faire de l'apprentissage dans
les entreprises
donc il faut savoir mettre la fonction
publique et les fonctionnaires pas
n'importe où pas n'importe comment mais
vraiment au coeur d'une problématique de
modernisation de notre société
bon ben je remercie d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et vous merci de nous
avoir suivi un c'est la fin d'europe de
la semaine prochaine vous retrouvez nos
rames
10 à cette même place d'ici là bonne
suite des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
bye